[Music]
among the stories in ursula kayla
green's tales from earthsea is that of
dark rose and diamond and at first
glance this looks like a love story and
it is indeed a love story between these
two who grow up with each other as
friends and eventually become lovers
there's a breakup there's a reuniting
and a very romantic end to it you could
say
but it's it's also a story about choices
and specifically
what we can call the choice of life the
commitment that one makes given
who one is
one's responsibilities and relationships
and also one's
talents
uh the selection that one makes from the
different paths in front of oneself and
about choosing again
later on
there's a number of choices
that diamond ends up making ultimately
taking him in the direction
of music but before that there's also
magic and then
his essentially family business life uh
one that's summed up in terms of
the language of duty getting and
spending outlaying income the profit and
the loss in which he's aligned with his
father as a matter of fact with each of
the choices he's going to be aligned
with somebody he can follow the route of
taking over the family business you know
growing into it through a kind of
apprenticeship and thereby being aligned
with his father who is very much looking
forward to that he can go to into magic
into wizardry
learning first from the local wizard and
then you know it suggested he should
actually go to rock and study there
or the life of a wandering musician one
who actually will achieve some high
repute and one that has the possibility
of being with his childhood love dark
rose often just called rose in this and
this is a very important set of choices
before us
before him and i was thinking you know
many of us don't have quite so many
choices because we may not have quite so
many talents and the decision may be
made for us so
you know diamond is in a rather enviable
position in some respects but also a
difficult position
in other respects so we begin with
diamond as a child and you know some
discussion about his mother and his
father
here we go
in the west of hovnor among hills
forested with oak and chestnut as the
town of glade a while ago the rich man
of that town was a merchant called
golden golden owned the mill that cut
the oak boards for the ships they built
in have north southport in
great port he owned the biggest chestnut
groves he owned the carts and hired the
carters that carried the timber and
chestnuts over the hills to be sold he
did very well from trees and when his
son was born his mother said we could
call him chestnut or oak maybe but the
father said diamond diamond being in his
estimation the one thing more precious
than gold so a little diamond grew up in
the finest house and glade a fat
bright-eyed baby a ruddy cheerful boy he
had a sweet singing voice a true ear and
a love of music so that his mother tully
called him song sparrow and skylark
among other loving names he trilled and
caroled about the house for he knew any
tune as soon as he heard it and he
invented tunes when he heard none
his mother had the wise woman tangle and
here we get another important character
coming in teach him the creation of aeon
the deed of the young king
and at sun return when he was 11 years
old he sang the wit he's saying the
winter carol for the lord of the western
land the lord and the lady praised the
boys singing and gave him a tiny gold
box with a diamond set in the lid
golden was a bit impatient with the
singing there are more important things
for you to do son and greater prizes to
be earned diamond thought his father
meant the business the loggers the
sawyers the sawmill the chestnut groves
the pickers the carters the carts all
that work and planning those complicated
adult matters he never felt it had much
to do with him so how was he to have as
much to do with it as his father
expected
but golden wasn't only thinking about
the business he'd observed something
about his son that had made him not
exactly set his eyes higher than the
business but glance above it from time
to time then shut his eyes what a
wonderful
stage setting and beginning so it turns
out as we're going to learn by reading
more that diamond not only has this
great talent for music which is not just
a mere mimetic
traits right he makes his own music when
nobody else is making music
and
for
magic magic in earthsea
is incredibly important
he also has this friendship
with the wise woman or the witch's
daughter
dark rose and they
play around together as kids do and do
magic together so
one of the things that that
golden is observing
is them doing some magic playing around
when he saw diamond come down the stairs
without touching the stairs he thought
his eyes had deceived him when a few
days later he saw the child float up the
stairs and he said can you do that
coming down and gold diamond said oh yes
like this and sailed back down as smooth
as a cloud on the south wind how did you
learn to do this he asks him and
diamond says i just sort of found out
and that's the way it is with nearly all
of the things he catches them playing a
game with rocks moving the rocks around
and you know when he asked them about it
rose says i just thought it up this game
right
and golden doesn't like
uh
dark rose she was both outspoken and
defensive rash and timid she was a girl
in a year younger than diamond and a
witch's daughter he wished his son would
play with boys his own age his own sort
from the respectable families of glade
and we find out later why things are
like this her her mother is not really
mothering her at all if dark rose asks
for something her mother will give it to
her but she doesn't show her an awful
lot of affection or care or foresight
and at one point dark rose asks her
why did you even have me if you didn't
really want to have a child and she says
well you know i've got to do midwifery i
kind of needed to know something about
being pregnant and having a child so
you're it you know so dark rose is is
you know
sort of on the out outside of a high
society there and uh diamond's family is
really in the center
his father golden has desires for him he
wants
uh diamond to continue in the family
business but he also recognizes that
that might not be the best path for him
here's a great line and golden's
understanding money was power but not
the only power
there were two others one equal
one greater there was birth when the
lord of the western land came to his
domain near glade golden was glad to
show him fealty the lord was born to
govern and to keep the peace as golden
was born to deal with commerce and
wealth each in his place and each noble
or common if he served well and honestly
deserved honor and respect so what we
see here is a sort of division of
society and different paths that one can
go
the lords are supposed to keep order
within the realm a very important
function as we see when you know there's
stories about disorder
and the merchants are supposed to keep
the economy going
and then he says
power of birth and power of money were
contingent and must be earned lest they
be lost
beyond the rich and lordly were those
called the men of power the wizards
their power the little exercise was
absolute
in their hands lay the fate of the long
kingless kingdom of the archipelago
if diamond had been born to that sort of
power if that was his gift all of
golden's dreams and plans of training
him in the business and helping him
expanding the karting route to a regular
trade and buying up the chestnut force
all those dwindled into
trifles
and so
you know he he talks to the local wizard
and finds out that
if if you have a talent like that and
you don't cultivate it it can really go
badly so he decides
well i've got to ask my son what he
wants to do and he gives diamond a
choice he doesn't simply impose it on
him as his father he actually
uh tells him that you yourself
have to choose as a man
um he says you know i've got this this
possibility for you
you must make your choice alone as a man
do you understand that
golden was earnest seeing his chance to
begin to wean the land the lad from his
mother she as a woman would cling but he
is a man would must learn to let go
and so he goes off and he begins to
study with
master hemlock before that he tells rose
you know i i have to go and do this and
rose is actually
not that unhappy about it she's like
well you're going to learn a lot of cool
stuff and maybe you can teach me that
stuff as well
as it's going to turn out studying with
master hemlock
is not learning an awful lot of wizardry
it's instead learning and memorizing
names
this goes back to some of the other
passages in the earthsea
stories about what learning is like for
wizards
uh
here we go
he had to memorize long long lists of
words words of power in the language of
the making plants and parts of plants
and animals and parts of animals and
islands and parts of islands parts of
ships parts of the human body the words
never made sense never made sentences
only lists long long lists so you can
imagine this is quite dry and it's not
only dry because it's a lot of
information
it's context-less
right there's nothing that's providing
it with a kind of
structure or meaning other than this
means this it's sort of like memorizing
a dictionary
and what we find is that diamond begins
actually setting some of these things to
music since he is musically inclined
hemlock talks about keeping the
equilibrium knowledge order in control
these words he said so often they made a
tune in diamond's head and saying
themselves over and over again knowledge
order and control
right when diamond put the list of names
to tunes he made up he learned them much
faster but then the tune would come as
part of the name and he would sing out
so clearly
that hemlock winced hemlocks was a very
silent house and he tries to do sendings
diamond to dark rows
and he finds that he can't really
contact her
eventually he decides
you know there's a crisis you could say
that's provoked because
hemlock says
son you really should go to rogue and
study there you're going to learn so
much more and diamond says are you sure
that i you know i'm
up to that do you think i ought to you
know
[Music]
there's a there's a kind of modesty
and he says
you should either go rogue or find a
wizard to teach you what you need
you need what i can teach you you need
the names but that's not your gift
you have to find something that will
cultivate your gift if you were to go to
rock i'd send a letter with you drawing
you to the particular attention of the
master summoner
summoner's art as leguin points out is
perhaps the most arcane
and dangerous of the arts of magic and
hemlock says maybe i'm wrong maybe your
gift is for pattern perhaps an ordinary
gift for shaping and transformation i'm
not sure and he says you are uncommonly
slow young man to recognize your own
capacities and he says i thought my gift
was for music
hemlock dismissed that with a flick of
his hand i'm talking about the true
art
the true art of magic and then hemlock
reveals something to him
i've been protecting you this whole time
you shouldn't go home if you go to rope
you'll be totally protected if you stay
here you can be under my protection but
if you go home you're not going to be
protected protected from what protected
from sexuality and the desires
of
you know having some sort of intimate
relation with his love
dark rose
wizards
at least in earth sea at that time
have to be
celibate they have to
bind themselves and they do so by
magical means quite often and they can
do so for others so
the reason why dark rose has not been
able to be contacted by diamond or to be
able to contact him herself which she
does as we we find out she tries to
is because
this wizard hemlock has been imposing a
bar
upon that he calls it protecting
diamond doesn't see it that way and
diamond runs away he doesn't want to go
to rope and he also doesn't want this
sort of protection and he goes to dark
rose who is very upset with diamond for
not responding to her
and she rejects him she pushes him away
and then he decides fine
not doing
magic i'm not going to spend time with
dark rose
i guess i'll go into the family business
and that is what he does
he chooses
the family business and leaves magic
behind
as we find out it's going to require a
little bit of a trick
to do
that and
golden is very happy about this right
um
here we go he's talking with his
his parents and he tells them i ran away
it's not the life i want
and then
golden says okay what did you decide you
want a pause this diamond said his voice
was level he looked neither at his
father nor his mother
ha said golden well i'll say i'm glad of
it son he ate a small pork pie and one
mouthful being a wizard going to rock
all of that never seemed real exactly
and with you here
with you off there i didn't know what
all this was for to tell you the truth
all my business if you're here it adds
up you see
it adds up but listen here did you just
run off from the wizard you know where
you're going the wizard returns part of
the fee and all that and golden is
happy that his son now is going to be
helping out golden was immensely happy
and quite unconscious of it it's that
kind of happiness that kind of joy that
a person has he had been feeling old but
that was nonsense he was in his prime
you know he says his wife says well well
well uh he says that to his wife all
rosie again got the apple of your eye
back home no more moping eh and
then uh
he says you know when he gets himself a
girl he'll be squared away living with
the wizards you know the way they are it
set him back a bit don't worry about
diamond he'll know what he wants when he
sees it and he says at least he's not
seeing the witch's girl that's that's
done with
and as it turns out the witch is no
longer friends with with his wife either
golden is a little bit oblivious to
what's going on
diamond focuses on the family business
and he learns the things that he has to
learn as we
mentioned a little bit before all of
this this stuff about profit and loss
the language of duty all of these things
that he needs to do
he says beyond that nothing there had
been illusions little spells pebbles
that turned to butterflies there'd never
really been a choice there was only one
way for him to go this is what he tells
himself
then
at this party that's being held where
they're hopefully going to do some
matchmaking for golden uh dark rose is
there with lobbies banned and they are
um playing territories with his band as
well
and they're they're all you know dancing
and drinking and stuff like that
and then
um
diamond and dark rose have time to talk
and she says what did you want diamond
and he says i wanted to ask you to go
away with me when
then when we quarreled i said it all
wrong i thought i thought i could go on
running away with you and play music
make a living together i wanted to say
that and then she says well you didn't
say that
and he says i know i said everything
wrong i did everything wrong i betrayed
everything the magic and the music and
you
i'm all right she said
are you i'm not really good on the fife
but i'm good enough what you didn't
teach me i can fill in with a spell if i
have to on the band they're all right
lobby isn't as bad as he looks nobody
fools with me we make a pretty good
living winter is i go stay with mother
and help her out so i'm all right what
about you die and he says
all wrong
and a little bit later on
she says well what's changed and he's
and he says
i made the wrong choice
once she said or twice twice
third time's the charm
and um she you know they go on a little
bit more
and he says
um
i don't understand why do you have to
stop doing one thing so you can do the
other and he says my father they don't
go together the money and the music and
then he asked her would you come back to
me would you go with me live with me
marry me dark rose
not in your father's house
anywhere run away but you can't have me
without the music or the music without
you
so he says does lobby need a harper and
she says if he wants a fife player
and he becomes
a musician he runs away
with her he has made a third choice no
longer
magic no longer
the you know sawmill and the accounts
and all that which by the way he used
magic to make himself pursue
single-mindedly
then he makes his third choice of life
and it has consequences it breaks his
father's heart golden made more money
than he'd ever done before all his deals
were profitable he grew immensely
wealthy he did not forgive his son
it would have made a happy ending but he
would not have it
so he had his tragedy there was nothing
but
shame and pain and anger for golden
tully his wife shared it with him for a
long time since she could see her son
only by lying to her husband which she
found it hard to do
but she as time went on and she heard
him spoken as diamond the sweet singer
of the west of hovnor diamond who had
harped and sung to the great lords in
the tower of the sword
her heart grew lighter
and once when golden was down at
southport she and tangled took a donkey
card and drove her over to easthill
where they heard diamond sing the lay of
the lost queen while rose sat with them
and little tully sat on tully's knee and
if not a happy ending that was a true
joy which may be enough to ask for
after all
so
choosing a life of music
every choice
comes with giving something up
this is the story that's being told it's
not necessarily one with a moral for us
like always follow your passion for all
your heart leguin doesn't make her
stories quite so simple as that
but we do have a very interesting
thematic going on here in what
diamond chooses ultimately love and
music
you